it's time for the lawn gene conosco a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the lawn gene which nor
watch company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the lawn
gene Kranz cope Larry lesser of the CBS
television news staff and Kenneth
Crawford national affairs editor for
Newsweek magazine our distinguished
guest for this evening is Henry J majed
a national commander of the American
veterans of World War two Mr McKay Dee I
understand you just come back from
Europe where you've been visiting the
world veterans Federation can you tell
us how do you as an American veteran
feel about these veterans of the
European war well I went over as an
observer to see what they were doing to
consolidate world opinion for peace and
it was interesting to see the veterans
of all the world gathered in a
convention or Congress of their own
without the barrier of government
protocol we talked together we discussed
the issues of International Affairs
together to see the representative of
Israel and the representative of Turkey
and the Arab states it down friendly
discuss all these matters it was a
source of wonderment to me and of great
gratification what came out of it
commander well I took from my
organization the International Affairs
mandates that we had discussed at our
convention similarly the veterans of
other countries brought the mandates of
their conventions into this general
Congress of all the world we discussed
the issues of the day and we decided
what the veteran of the world would
think about those issues for instance
the veterans from Yugoslavia and the
veterans from Italy sat down together
just at a time when Trieste was at the
boiling point
they decided that they would go home and
ask their people and the veterans of
their organization to keep the tension
at a minimum feeling that some way a
proper and a dignified and a solution
would be found so that there would be
peace in the world and freest would not
cause war misma Haiti I trust there were
no veterans of the Red Army there but
may I ask you you fellows really
pacifists no we are not pacifists we are
trying to perfect the brotherhood of man
and world peace we are principled
citizens of America who if our
principles of democracy are infringed
upon will fight for our country we will
fight for those things that we believe
will lead to the dignity of mankind and
the Brotherhood of mankind and in that
connection commander what's your
position on Korea for example they get
to a specific case well my convention
decided that if the talks in Korea
failed that they would advocate all-out
war so that no that the principal of
non-aggression that the United Nations
has enunciated would be upheld but not a
return to limited war that we do not
believe in a limited a return to limited
war Oh mr. media I gather that the
veterans you visited were members of the
free world that's right with the
exception of Yugoslavia Yugoslavia had
their delegates there and they were very
cooperative and I believe they are
genuinely entering into this world
convention of veterans in an attempt to
bring a common problem that faces us all
together so that we can enunciate a new
mode of life for the whole world there
are German a Japanese veterans in this
or there is a German unit which was just
introduced at this latest convention we
feel that we cannot exclude any nation
and we must bring all nations in as
rapidly as possible otherwise how can
you have world peace with only half the
world sitting at the counsel table well
commander I gather you learned a few
things to some of these European
soldiers you think they learn anything
from you American veterans I think we
did America's service in this way they
saw that we've just weren't maintaining
our
point of view that we would generously
sit down with them in a friendly way and
discuss their point of view I came away
with the feeling that there was a
tremendous force generated a tremendous
force mobilized for world peace because
I was treated as a friend and a neighbor
by all of these veterans besides having
the mission of keeping the peace in this
organization you do some specific things
like rehabilitation of veterans
themselves do you know yes we do there
are 4 million veterans in the world
outside of America who are disabled and
in need of prosthetic devices for
instance we promised the gentleman from
Israel that we would bring one of his
men who does not have an arm to America
so that he can have the type of
prosthetic device that Harold Russell
where's he's being brought here by my
organization and will be given a new
life with this new prosthetic device
this is a particular contribution you
Americans can make it isn't it since
you're probably ahead in this country on
prosthesis we are the leaders today in
the world of veteran rehabilitation and
in the use of new prosthetic devices for
instance when we were in Holland how
Russell went in to see a veteran who
hadn't been out of his house in over 10
years the men broke into tears when
Harold showed him how he could use his
new prosthetic devices and he agreed to
take training with the help of our world
veterans fund in order that he too would
have a new life just like Harold had
arrived at a new way of life after being
having his hands decapitated welcome and
right I gather that the veterans of
Europe didn't get quite as good deal as
the veterans of United States were they
envious of you chaps well of course you
understand we are very well favoured
economically in this company there's a
very great comparison between our way of
life and the way of life of the people
in European countries but I sense no
sense of jealousy I did since a great
need in the hearts of those people and I
did sense that they wanted our help and
would cooperate with us in every way
possible to achieve world peace
and to help these poor veterans who need
help well incidentally sir I understand
that your am vet organization favors
universal military training you get
anywhere on that well we are making a
big fight for universal military
training and I'll tell you why the
veterans of the last war have been
called back many of them to fight in
korea and we feel that a man who's given
four or five years of his life in one
war shouldn't be called back and have
his family and his life disrupted again
so we're going before Congress on
january the 27th to testify and to urge
upon them the passage of universal
military training realistically
commander do you have much hope that
this Congress will pass it no I think
that there's great pressure upon
Congress to pass a bill yes because
there's a tremendous manpower need in
our armed forces the last time I
discussed this question with the head of
our armed forces he told me that their
biggest problem was manpower and
certainly we need to set up machinery to
get that manpower there's a section
minutes though isn't it on the ground
that this won't work along with the
draft and that you must wait until the
draft is no longer needed you agree to
that well I suppose we'll have to keep
selective service until we get a
universal military training bill but so
many inequities have arisen under it
that certainly they'll have to bring the
legislation up to date miss mahalia
understand you're a mess Association
favors the non deferment of college
students from selective service but
we're also told now that Russia is
training more engineers and scientists
than we are now would you favor taking
these people out of college and taking
them out of the technical services I
agree that we need a train core of
scientists because warfare is now in a
highly scientific state but I also think
it's inequitable to distinguish between
the men who can afford to go to college
and the man who cannot I suppose some
exceptions in universal military
training will have to be made to see
that we get a proper core of scientists
but I don't like to think that a poor
boy has to go to war
and a boy who can afford college doesn't
have to go you think the deferment of
technically trained people is
undemocratic well I think there's a
point there I may ask you this how about
these young fellows from Korea are they
joining up in veterans organization one
here that they're none joiners well I
don't think that's so I feel that for
instance we made a terrific fight for
the benefits under the GI Bill of Rights
so that they would be given to the
Korean veteran and I think they sense
that they need the veterans
organizations in order to forward their
point of view the fight that we made for
the GI Bill of Rights for Korean
veterans certainly has set us out as an
organization that will be supported by
the Korean veteran and I think they are
joining yesterday that there are a lot
of complaints about Korean veterans
they're not getting the same break you
fellas got on the GI Bill of Rights on
home loans and mortgages and things like
that I don't think that so I think that
essentially and substantially they are
getting the same thing that we are of
course the interest rate for housing for
mortgages for guaranteed mortgages for
tis his hire but then interest rates are
higher all around and of course while we
fought against raising that interest
rate we couldn't we couldn't stand the
pressure and we had to give him because
interest rates had risen universally
throughout the company mr. Mahaney why
several veterans organizations you speak
of yours particularly naturally there
are several now why should there be well
it's this way there are 11 million
veterans of World War two are better and
they're all of one age group essentially
they have something in common other
veterans organizations more or less
arose from the earlier age groups
ambit's consist of one age group from
one war we are chartered exclusively by
Congress for the veterans of World War
two see well mr. Mahim ask you is the
final question what do you veterans
really want how do you want to be
treated from by the rest of the United
States well we don't feel it were any
exception the only thing that we want to
do is to advance the cause of the poor
disabled veteran
widow and his orphan there are many
veterans who are so disabled that they
cannot look after themselves we want to
do that job we want to look after the
mothers of these boys who have been left
behind we want to look after their wives
we feel as a job to do we want to do
that job we want to be able to come in
on legislation affecting these veterans
and their families but we asked no no
different treatment from any other
citizen thank you very much commander
hey it's been a great pleasure to have
you here tonight thank you very much the
opinions that you've heard our speakers
express tonight have been entirely their
own the editorial board for this edition
of the lawn gene Cronus Cove was Larry
lesser and Kenneth Crawford our
distinguished guest was Henry J majed a
national commander of the American
veterans of World War two